let's hear from mark murphy the
president
and ceo of the green bay packers and
before we hear from him
let's remember it was just a week or so
ago
that he wrote at packers.com
that he believes it's in the best
interest
to resolve this divisive situation for
both sides to say
as little as possible publicly
there it is as little as possible we are
working to resolve the situation and
realize that the less
both sides say publicly the better
with that as the backdrop let's hear
what mark murphy had to say publicly
about the aaron rodgers situation late
last
week i'm often reminded though
uh ted thompson most of you know just a
great general manager
passed away this past year
excuse me earlier this year uh often
talked about aaron that he's a comp or
and it wasn't just aaron a lot of
different players he would say he's a
complicated fella
so i'll just uh say that
you boy uh look uh hey
we we know he's a complicated fella you
know he's a complicated fella
all of you out there who pay any
attention to the national football
league realize
that aaron rodgers is a complicated
fella you don't make him any
less complicated by saying it
when you are the guy who runs the
football team that is supposedly trying
to unburn the bridge between rogers
and the organization what is going on
here chris
i really do think mark murphy is trying
to get him to not show up mike i
when i when i read those comments i went
uh
florio might be right mark murphy might
actually not want rogers to be there at
all
like to me like the big thing to me and
first off reading it and hearing it is a
different level
actually reading it makes mark murphy
look a little better when you hear it
and the way he ends it and just i'll
leave it at that
like that's more insulting you'll leave
it at that oh
okay like what i really want to do is go
mark what the hell is mark murphy doing
is what i want to say it is complete
bullcrap
what he's doing actually it really is if
aaron rodgers was doing this and still
putting out cryptic messages over the
last week
oh my gosh every talk show you would
have had seven headlines this weekend on
pro football talk i'm not trying to be a
jerk but you know that's the way it
would be
if it was aaron rodgers yeah yes right
it's messed up
look i know have i have i not said it no
you're right
you're right have i not said what
they're trying to do i know i'm just
i'm glorifying the the magnitude of this
if the roles were reversed and like you
know back to the letter too you know hey
thanks ken
hey ken the bastards that are dragging
things down are the bastard you're
writing to
i mean sorry i don't mean to call mark
murphy that but he's the one that's
created this issue
and now he's fanning the the the fire i
mean that
that's to me like i don't know it's
inexcusable it's unprofessional
it's cryptic it's jerky it's not how you
run the organization i really have
nothing positive to say about it
two explanations it just kind of
happened inadvertently or it was
strategic
and i'm going to assume that we're
talking about
folks who operate their business at a
high level
understand what it means to say things
publicly and that there are no accidents
nothing gets
blurted out now if it was inadvertent it
still gives us a
glimpse into what he's really thinking
and and i agree with you chris when he
pins the tail on the donkey with i'll
leave it at that
what that means is there's a hell of a
lot more i'd like
yeah right right it is unflattering to
this guy
i'll leave it at that he's a complicated
fella
i'll leave it at that meaning
what would come next would not fall in
the bucket
of abject praise of aaron rodgers
so again it's either on purpose or it
just sort of happened
either way i think that it pushes that
needle
further toward us realizing that if mark
murphy had his way
aaron rodgers never plays football again
or at a minimum
doesn't play this year they net
between salary bonuses that
aren't paid bonuses that are recovered
more than 30 million dollars that they
can use to reinvest in other players and
they find out what jordan love
has and you know what if jordan loves
stinks mark murphy didn't draft him
brian goody koontz did murphy's got the
ultimate safe harbor here
for this thing to blow up and if love
doesn't work out well
it's it's brian goodacoon's fault not
mine he's the scout
i'm not he's the one that evaluated
jordan love and he thought he was going
to be good
and if there's anyone to blame blame him
so yeah i really think that's what
murphy wants to find out let's find out
what this guy has
let's not have to be held hostage by
this complicated fella
who's going to be saying
passive-aggressive things or aggressive
aggressive things all year long let's
just not deal with it
let's move forward that's what we do we
move forward from brett favre we're
moving forward from aaron rodgers yeah
well good luck
i mean he you know to me not saying
that's right yeah not
it's no no i think you're not that's
what he wants no you're right i mean
listen
the way it looks i i kind of agree with
you right now i mean
i do and you know off of that though
that's nice that's what he
that maybe that's what he wants yeah i'm
a with you i don't think it's right of
course i don't think it's right
i mean he created the problem the packer
shareholders they're gonna have they're
gonna have to have a little
conversation at some point wait yeah
he's not the owner of the team
he's the guy though this is control of
the guy who drafted this first round
pick at quarterback and could have
stepped in and said no don't do it this
is stupid
we're asking for career suicide and
we're going to ruin the organization
he didn't so he should be held
accountable and i'll tell you with these
little comments too
if he does not want if this like the
main thing is like you're talking about
and what you've been on like you know
this is all about maybe he really
doesn't want him there and he does we'll
save the money
and don't have to deal with it all that
this isn't helping aaron rodgers the
type
of guy who reads this and goes this
freaking ass
beep okay i'm gonna show this guy
all about what i got i bet you aaron
rodgers went out and worked harder this
weekend because he goes man i can't wait
to get to green bay
and just totally ruin mark murphy's life
and i'm just going to play awesome
and ruin everybody's time and i'm going
to make it so hard
do they not again obviously they do not
know who they're dealing with
they don't there's obviously like a
stupid disconnect there where they don't
really know
this complicated fella they might need
to do a little more
research on them because this is the
type of stuff in my opinion
of a rogers he's going to come back and
go hey up yours i'm here and i'm better
than ever
and he's gonna have lots of cryptic text
messages if you keep poking them this
way
there's a chance that they have
underestimated him or to borrow a line
from the great michael scott that they
are properly
estimating him and this is chapter three
of mark murphy's effort to poke the bear
just enough to get the absolute
best performance from the bear and i go
back to tyler dunn's story from bleacher
report two years ago
when murphy seemed pleased that all this
crap was hitting the fan
about rogers and former head coach mike
mccarthy
and murphy made the comment along the
lines of maybe this will
upset some people in a good way well
drafting jordan love
upset someone in a good way maybe this
comment
aimed at upsetting aaron rodgers in a
good way if it was intentional
if it was deliberate if there's a method
to the madness here
it is that the end result is exactly
what you're predicting
rogers goes out and works harder rogers
is determined to come to town
and be even better than last year and
ultimately win that super bowl and
and pull the paul crew moment yeah at
the end where he
scoops up the game ball and sticks it in
murphy's stomach and says go put this in
your trophy case and they win a super
bowl and then they trade him
i mean maybe they are trying to
manipulate him here maybe i just think
that
i think it's past that yeah the
manipulation's over i think that's one
of the reasons why he's so pissed off he
knows he's been manipulated
yeah i agree too and and i think you
know
with all that you said there you know
again yeah maybe it motivated and did
things like that
but i don't know i don't i don't have
enough history or enough
knowledge or enough evidence to ever
think mark murphy's
this smart that he's this tactical and
doing these type of things i'm sorry
i just can't you don't you don't you
don't become the ceo of the package i
don't know
the job for over and over about
to a degree but i don't think to this
group to degree i mean maybe he said
that when tyler dunn back when wrote
that article because he met man
maybe mike mccarthy will get an order
maybe it wasn't about aaron rodgers i i
don't really know mccarthy was fired
and so that was our he was already fired
by then okay so so
listen either way but again
as somebody who's been around football
my whole life you've been following it
you know your whole life anybody i
talked to who's been around the sport
nobody can make sense of the draft pick
the situation the handling of this whole
situation
nothing and the smart play ultimately
what we're talking about is if you
wanted
super bowl was not to take a quarterback
last year in the first round that was
not if the ultimate goal was to get
super bowl it wasn't waste two picks
on something that will not help us get
to the super bowl
at all and i think that's where i always
come back to to go yeah
no mark murphy's not that smart they
just messed this up
yeah they packaged a one and a four
tonight from 30 to 26 to get jordan lava
after justin jefferson
went off the board after brandon iuke
went off the board when the 49ers
leapfrogged the packers a couple of
receivers they wanted instead of
drafting the receiver at 30 or trading
down
yeah and taking a chase claypool later
wouldn't that have been something if the
packers
have done that they they decide to
leap up and activate the aaron rodgers
succession plan the secret folder that
someone was carrying around
for use at an unknown time for an
unknown reason
here we go and you know what chris it it
may have been
as simple as they feared
at some point this complicated fella was
gonna hold them hostage
the way that brett favre did and they
were gonna be stuck
with some slappy as the backup if aaron
rodgers just decided
out of the blue i'm done like barry
sanders right before training camp
i'm done i'm out and they got nobody at
that point i hear you i hear you but we
just we we have no evidence that that
was
anywhere you know that that's just
it's hypothetical because i mean we have
we knew with brett favre
there was inklings you heard rumors you
know he wasn't sure how much he wanted
to play
none of that was available or or a
talking point with aaron rodgers
nobody was thinking that at all i mean
he wasn't hinting at that towards anyone
or anything like that so
i understand and you're right history
could you know maybe
make them think about that to a degree
but rogers as you've pointed out i think
has been
so careful to not be like brett favre
that i don't think he's ever given those
signals to justify
maybe some of those actions we're
talking about we don't know what he's
no you're right we don't directly i know
i know you know what
what we and and when you accept the fact
that he's complicated
you you plan for all possible
permutations
sure and you don't want to give him that
opening where he takes over
and then he turns the tables on you
unexpectedly and leaves you high and dry
just for sport i mean i again i'm just
trying to understand why they did what
they did
in april of 2020 as we try to understand
why mark murphy said what he said
just a few days ago and what we know is
coming up on july 26th
the only thing we know right now about
the package yeah july 26
shareholders meeting who boy up
lambeau field here they come now this is
different than a normal corporation
you can't sell the stock no one can go
out and try to accumulate a big
block of it and try to have a hostile
takeover this is something that the
packers
implemented back in the 20s when they
didn't have money and they needed to
raise cash and they've had like four or
five stock
issuances over the years and it isn't
real power
but and and i haven't studied the
articles of incorporation or the bylaws
you would think there's some mechanism
if the fans slash shareholders aren't
happy with what's going on
at a minimum they can voice it yeah they
could take action
i mean i got the impression fans were
pissed off about what murphy said
that this backfired on him if the goal
was to try to
win in the court of public opinion that
you know he was trending on twitter on
saturday after these comments came down
right now it wasn't in a good way
no definitely because it's just you know
i think even people who might be like
okay rogers is a pain in the butt he's a
diva and he's like they see these and if
they're paying attention to
the sports media over the last two weeks
they see both of those things and go
well
that's kind of messed up what are you
talking about most times
when if a player said something as
stupid as
hey ken you know with the whole don't
let the bastards get you down
hey ken yeah this roger situation has
really divided the fan base like
we would come on here and go wait there
was a way better answer for that player
to just come out with
and like so mark murphy here you go i
guess about to talk to you like a player
here
like you could have just said hey ken
hey
we got a lot of respect for aaron
rodgers it's part of the business
we'll fit this figured out somehow but
instead you took a shot
and that's bullcrap in my opinion and
there you are you're going to expect the
quarterback to be different and the
players to be different
and and listen to your instructions and
not do public things
but you're going to take that into your
own hands and do it the way you want to
when it comes time for
you you know doing what you want to do
and that's not cool players are going to
see that too they're not going to
respect that
at all whatever happens on july 26th
mark murphy will speak at some point and
he'll have a chance to
either make things better or make things
worse with what he says
and look the prevailing view continues
to be that the packers
aren't going to budge here there's no
reason to budge here if they would try
to trade aaron rodgers right now they're
not going to get as much as they would
get
after the 2021 season but you know what
chris
if what happened on thursday yeah when
murphy said what he said
was inadvertent unscripted unplanned and
he's just the point where he can't help
himself and they're concerned about what
may happen on july 26th
i don't know it's a month and a half
from now a lot can change it definitely
a short period of time in the nfl
could they wake up one day and decide
we are going to explore this it is in
everyone's best interest to just be done
with it to quit playing this game that
this distraction
is overwhelming the team i don't think
it will happen but we have to at least
have it on
the edge of the radar screen as a
possibility that the packers will have a
change of heart maybe mark murphy starts
to get some pressure from the board of
directors
as to what is it that you're really
trying to do here you know he answers to
a broader board
which consists of a lot of green bay
area business people
there's an executive committee him and
maybe six others
i yeah and and typically if you know
what you're doing
all those people are on board with you
maybe what's happened over the last week
could cause some of those folks to start
saying
mark what yeah what's the plan what are
we really trying to prove
yeah right what's our end game here
why are we fighting with this guy who
has only performed his job at the
highest possible
level since he became the starter in
2008.
why are we trying to piss this guy off
why are we trying
you know future quarterbacks and players
are going to be looking at how we
treated
aaron rodgers no doubt i think that's
how they're going to get treated at some
point why are we doing this
no there's no doubt that's definitely
going to be something i mean you know
now they have jordan love but if they're
trying to attract big time free agent
quarterbacks maybe two three
four years from now the jordan love
thing didn't work out
yeah that's gonna be thought of for sure
you know
nonetheless like these comments are
gonna like you know
they're they're gonna have shock waves
through the locker room guys notice this
it's aaron rodgers they're gonna know
what he's done for the organization
playing wise
so yeah they're going to lose lack of
respect there for mark mark murphy for
for what's done there
but you're right i mean at some point
what is going to be done
uh you know you're getting close to
football here i don't
i don't understand the the point of
continuing to
take jabs at rogers i would still think
even at this point with mark murphy like
hey
it looks like he's probably going to
come back and play let's start thinking
about
how we going to be the best green bay
packers team of 2021
you know start you know maybe massaging
it publicly and saying
positive things get going on like the
positive track for the football team
forget it and you know like the trade
thing you're right it could arise at any
at any point any situation yeah they
probably can't maximize like we've
talked about but for a guy like aaron
rodgers
you know that they could they just got
to get one team to just say yeah we want
it
all right we're sold let's go they're
going to get close to maximization for a
player like aaron rodgers regardless so
i i would think teams like denver give
one more call to green bay
you know this last month before training
camp starts just to see where it's at
and maybe a few other teams and we'll
see what green bay does from there
i i you know it it really
is is fascinating that this is happening
there's only been two times in the
history of the national football league
that the reigning mvp
did not play for his team the next year
and both of those were
retirements norm van brocklen and jim
brown
it's amazing the idea that the mvp
a guy who wanted over guys like patrick
mahomes
right russell wilson lamar jackson aaron
rodgers at age 37 with
the finest season arguably of his career
and he's caught in this mess
that is as much the team's making as it
is his and arguably it's more
the team's making yeah one one thing one
thing that just came to mind
that that maybe we'll see and hear from
aaron rodgers i
i check his twitter page once a day just
to see if there's anything there
we saw him playing the guitar and
singing taylor swift right
in hawaii the avril lavigne song
complicated wouldn't it be great if he
learned that
and sang that like did a little karaoke
with complicated is a little fu to
mark murphy and we see that on social
media that would be nice well that
happens
hold on i just my i just lost a piece of
my brain
did you how do you know avril lavigne
and complicated like where did that come
from and how did you pull that song out
of your butt out of nowhere
all of a sudden where did that cut what
do you think where do you think i've
been for the last 50 not listening i
have lived
on the planet how do you know that you
don't know me not listening to him
you know me yeah i know you're pretty i
have been you don't look like the kind
of guy that's going down into the barn
listening to avril lavigne and singing
complicated
that's what i i felt like maybe i don't
now
now look there there is a way that you
can be
aware of the song and not particularly
like the song right not particularly
have it on
your playlist oh you're too you don't
know what it is yeah you know the title
you're in too deep though now you like
the song you're in
you're you like it it's on your playlist
no i don't no i don't no i don't know
i don't know opening the show tomorrow
florio dancing to
can you think of another song that has
complicated in the title it was the
first one i thought of he's a
complicated fella no there's no song
called complicated fellow so i had to
settle for what i could
find or at least think of in my brain
while we were talking yeah
i no you're right i just i know i
wouldn't have thought of any song or
anything to deal with complicated let
alone avril lavigne i just would have
not i
just i was shocked so wait just wait
yeah he's gonna get that guitar back out
he's going to learn that he's going to
play that one chord that he learned
and uh it's and they're going to sing
complicated
there can't not be a response from aaron
rodgers
there can't be silence he's got to say
something he's got to do
something doesn't he i actually don't
think he does i think this is perfect
i think this is perfect if i'm him now
you just sit back
they they look like the idiots and the
jerks right now don't do anything
just get ready for football send me make
some twitter and instagram videos that
you throw in lasers and spirals all over
the place
do that sell to the fan base you're all
in on football and here we go
green bay looks like the unprofessional
jerks here they're the ones that
like you like you just said i think they
deserve more of the blame than rogers
and i'm not saying he's perfect
but they certainly from everything we
know and i know we don't know everything
but yeah they deserve it and rogers i
think right now
in the the court of public opinion could
could look better than than them when
this is all said and done
and here's a reason for him to say and
do nothing at this point from avril
lavigne to napoleon bonaparte
never interrupt your enemy when your
enemy is making a mistake
yeah right right good advice right like
bill belichick
uh no noticing there's chaos on the
seattle seahawks sidelines
call time i don't call timeout they seem
flustered and they're gonna mess this up
yeah there's something to that it's a
good quote i like that one better than
avril lavigne and complicated
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports